ces dernières années les traitements
contre le cancer ont beaucoup progressé
avec des chimiothérapies plus ciblés et
l'efficacité avérée de l'immunothérapie
et maintenant une molécule expérimentale
développé par un chercheur québécois
pourrait éventuellement offrir une
nouvelle option
des obstacles et encore des obstacles
qu'importe face à l'adversité il faut
garder le cap droit vers l'objectif je
suis probablement chercheurs très
déterminé très persévérant qui aime bien
se tenir debout devant ses idées et de
les amener à terme est-ce que je suis
rêveur je suis plus quelqu'un avec une
vision qu'un rail la vision est
essentielle mais dans les faits ce n'est
que le premier pas
il faut être capable de surmonter les
échecs faut prendre peur de se faire
lancer par terre et de se relever
innovation et persévérance c'est ce qui
a défini les 15 dernières années de
recherche dans mon laboratoire
[Musique]
originaire de montréal luc berthiaume à
concrétiser sa vision dans l'ouest
canadien je suis arrivé à edmonton en
1995 si l'université d'alberta me
voulait absolument ils m'ont offert dix
fois plus d'argent que l'université de
montréal l'université laval mais dix
fois plus d'argent vu qu'on a juste une
chance de bien commencer à rechercher
une occasion que je ne pouvais pas
refuser
sa vision est pour le moins audacieuse
développer un médicament pour traiter le
cancer on parle ici d'une pilule à
prendre une fois par jour d'un confort
de son domicile
notre médicament cible de façon
préférentielle les cellules cancérigènes
et alla jusqu'à maintenant selon toutes
nos évidences scientifiques d'épargner
les cellules normales
un médicament oral loin de la
traditionnelle chimiothérapie l'idée
semble trop belle miraculeuse diront
certains y'a rien de miraculeux de
montmirat que vient souvent limayrac ça
s'explique pas mais ça s'est même pas de
la magie c'est lé résultat d'années de
recherche qui culmine en ce médicament
là c'est le processus scientifique dans
toute sa beauté et sa pureté
sa pilule expérimental porte le nom de
code pc helix 00 points comment agit
cette molécule
parmi les milliers deuxième produite par
nos cellules le laboratoire s'intéresse
à deux d'entre elles la haine mt 1 et la
n mt2
campc l'x 001 entre dans la cellule
saine il se lie à nmt 1 pour stopper son
action
heureusement la lmp2 est là pour prendre
la relève
dans la cellule cancéreuse il n'ya que
nmt un nmt 2 est absente et capable de
prendre la relève alors quand pc l'x 001
se lie à nm t1 la cellule cancéreuse
meurent car cette enzyme est essentiel à
sa survie
c'est un peu comme celle courait sur une
patte sont plus faciles à trébucher
qu'est ce que quelqu'un qui court avec
deux pattes en cible à l'ancien mt 1 qui
reste dans les cellules cancérigènes
avec notre médicament on a des effets
très très très sélectif pour tuer les
cellules cancérigènes
un médicament anticancer les médecins en
rêve depuis des décennies mais un
recherche l'espoir fait souvent place à
la déception je les centaines d'e-mails
et des centaines de téléphones de gens
qui veulent faire partie de nos études
cliniques autant j'ai peur de les
décevoir autant je suis confiant selon
nos données scientifiques que le composé
va fonctionner les données qui lui donne
espoir proviennent principalement de la
souris lorsqu'on traite nos souris avec
pc l'ex 001 qui est notre molécule
championne jusqu'à l'instant on observe
dans quatre types de cancer du sein une
éradication complète de toutes les
cellules cancérigènes de façon
uniforme pendant de dix jours on a
éliminé toutes les cellules cancérigènes
dans toutes les souris mais on a aussi
des effets des effets impressionnants au
niveau des cancers du poumon et du
cancer du sein
si les résultats qu'on a obtenus chez
les souris qui se transpose chez
l'humain on anticipe que les tumeurs
vont régresser de façon très rapide une
fois qu'on va avoir atteint la
concentration pharmacologique efficace
chez l'humain et si on a bien hâte de
voir si c'est ça qui va se passer
les vertus de pc l'ex 001 doivent
maintenant être confrontés à la réalité
on passe alors aux essais cliniques
60 patients seront répartis entre
vancouver edmonton et toronto
au printemps prochain montréal deviendra
le quatrième set décès les volontaires
recrutés sont en phase terminale on a
tout tenté mais plus rien ne fonctionne
les deux tiers sont atteints de lymphome
les autres ont reçu un diagnostic de
cancer du sein du poumon ou du côlon
[Musique]
edmonton alberta 24 septembre 2021
madame dirty work souffre de lymphome de
stade iv leur cancer du sang
aujourd'hui elle est la toute première
patiente à prendre une dose de pc helix
0,01 on doit établir la bonne posologie
celle qui produira le maximum d'effet
pour le minimum d'inconvénients la façon
dont nos deux techniques vont se
dérouler c'est un processus de doses
progressives
on commence une dose très faible où on
n'anticipe pas de toxicité n'anticipe
pas de voir des effets cliniques
significatifs dès le début mai dans six
mois d'après moi ça devrait commencer
est intéressant
madame woods accepte de passer le
scanner en plus de remettre des
échantillons de sang et d'uriné
c'est la seule façon de savoir si le
médicament fonctionne
[Musique]
ce qui fonctionne chez la souris n'est
pas un gage de succès chez l'humain
comment malamud réagira-t-elle
impossible de le prévoir cependant
certains effets secondaires sont tout de
même attendues notre médicament est très
différent de la chimiothérapie
conventionnelle en ce fait que notre
médicament n'attaque pas l'adn comme la
chimio conventionnel donc on s'entend
avoir beaucoup moins d'effets
secondaires parce que nous mais notre
médication c'est une médecine de
précisions elles ciblent les cellules
cancérigènes dans nos études de
biosécurité chez les animaux on a vu que
les effets secondaires principaux
étaient au niveau du côlon et de la
diarrhée de la déshydratation chez les
humains c'est des effets secondaires qui
sont très facilement contrôler ou plus
facilement contrôler que les effets
secondaires de la chimio
et si luc berthiaume avait raison si son
entêtement lui permettait de trouver ce
que tout le monde cherche
cette force prend racine dans quelque
chose de grand vous savez il ya
plusieurs sortes d'amour il ya l'amour
maternel fraternelle l amour des animaux
il ya toutes sortes d'amour mais l'amour
d'autrui c'est ce qui a guidé ma
progression scientifiques de faire une
différence dans la vie des gens un amour
et tout ça c'est une histoire d'amour
mais un petit peu différente
[Musique]